hey folks it's Thursday what we put up
this morning the one of my witching hour
yeah this with all the stories and stuff
so hopefully you guys are enjoying that
I think there's four stories on that one
about murders mm-hmm including some
Edgar Allan Poe also got a couple things
that I want to talk about I don't think
I told you this but remember how I said
that um I'm looking to like upgrade the
memory on this laptop yeah um I actually
went ahead and got that oh you did okay
so but the thing about it is though it's
um I ordered it and I guess because
Amazon like they have it in stock but
because they're prioritizing stuff
that's like essential and everything so
they're saying I might not get it so
like April 30th which you know it's
whatever fair enough well then annum I
will tell you that I got that switch to
the dryer oh you did yeah yeah our dryer
broke yeah a little switch on the door
um the door and it's still tumbled yeah
like break the middle of a pandemic
which can yeah but then the second that
happened it also stopped heating so
somehow supposed to shorten that switch
that's what I figured yeah it thinks the
door is open so it doesn't turn the yeah
the heating element on okay but it
doesn't know that the door is open to it
doesn't know it doesn't know whether
it's open or closed it thinks it's open
I guess I don't understand it dumb dryer
you would think that if you thought that
it was open that it would run heating
element and just says they're in tunnels
but that happened at the same time you
said Liz I'm diagnosing the goddamn
those two simple sidetracks those two
symptoms happen simultaneously on their
dryer so it's got to be that way well
it's got to be this thing out of here
it's got to be the same thing it's what
what are the chance what is the chance
that we've had that dryer a long time
now and I think we gotta replace that
element oh wait a second hand didn't we
yeah and I replaced that and it's one of
those damn you almost said eugenics I
said generic one of the generic drives
one of the generic dryers that head
injury yeah it's one of those generic
dry
that's sold by five six different
companies you know that front loader
yeah maybe that's the washing machine
I'm not sure I don't remember I look at
it like every other day but yeah that's
and it's like a generic dryer and like
five different [ __ ] big names sell it
so it's got a lot of either it's easy to
find parts for it it's just but I know
it's like um just a minor inconvenience
but it is kind of a pain like to have
your [ __ ] dryer break in the middle
and you know I don't think there's any
like repair shops or anything well it
would come on yeah that'll like send
because that's not considered like I
just just looked it up myself and so
that's all it is I can I can fix that
your stuff pop the top of it off ya know
it's not hard to it's like two screws
four screws to access it yeah that's
what I'm saying I like that like that
the last time we're going to do that
element hit take the whole [ __ ] back
over off yeah that guy had to come to
this like that was a good thing good
thing I you know good thing I wasn't
forced to do that I could have done that
I [ __ ] can't stand working on shits
all sheet metal yeah get cut up
sometimes yeah yeah like I said it's
kind of minor but it's kind of a big
inconvenience so yeah um so I ordered
like the new thing apparently I'm not
super tech savvy or anything like that
um because this Mac laptop that I have
it's a patent what do you call it power
book or whatever the [ __ ] they call it
yeah um this is actually from 2008 late
2008 so it's actually quite old and from
what I could determine you can't put any
more than like eight gigs in there like
it has four yeah but apparently I mean
there there are memory cards that'll go
up to 16 gigs but apparently they're not
compatible with ones this old okay but
the eight gig ones are it's like it's
two slots and then like each of them is
four you know what I mean so you have to
like pretty much unscrew the bottom and
take out the one that's in there if
there are any in there and then put them
in the two little slots it looks pretty
easy like I bookmarked the well we only
use this for certain things you don't
need much more memory than a D yeah I
just kind of wanted because I kept
getting into especially if I'm doing
like a lot of audio recording or a lot
of video recording or something like
that I have to throw stuff away like
immediately otherwise everything just
starts slowing down and I get
like all these [ __ ] problems they
might solve a lot of problems yeah so I
went ahead and ordered that but like I
said it'd probably be the end of the
month oh and somebody like on the
YouTube show because I was talking about
the Egypt game that I was making and
Shea Stewart who commented on their
about that reminded me of this book that
I read when I was a kid and you'd
probably like be really into it kind of
a why a book called the Egypt game and
she said it was by Zilpha Keatley
Schneider and I was like holy crap I've
read like a couple of her books when I
was growing up like the witches of worm
and the Headless keep it which is one of
my favorite books in childhood so they
had like a used one on Amazon so when I
got the [ __ ] memory cards I just
wanted him threw that on there too
because it was only a couple bucks okay
so I want to read that as well also
speaking of games I just got a message
from our newest patron Eric who also
ordered one of my games from the game
crafter so he said he's very excited
about playing it like I said I mentioned
it on the show yesterday probably but um
the game crafter they've shut down there
you know the manufacturing part
robots are on Bruce yeah until the 24th
so they said like you can still do
orders and stuff like that it's just and
we'll like start filling the orders as
soon as we get back but they just didn't
want like everyone working in close
quarters and [ __ ] like that and here's
something I didn't even think of until
this was just kind of like in the
sidebar like on another [ __ ] article
I was reading I didn't even think about
this but they're like well if you have
like a loved one died like during this
like not of coronavirus or anything like
that but just dying like just because
they died um you can't really have a
funeral because everyone's not really
supposed to be there so they're talking
about wold should we just put it off or
should we live stream it I'm like oh
that's so weird like really weird the
live stream of funeral I guess people do
it nowadays though but maybe it's not
that weird but it just does yeah it's
like it was something I hadn't even
thought of but then like I saw the thing
like the little article and I was like
oh [ __ ] that would suck wouldn't it I'm
bitching about a dryer breaking but
China was cremating them all you know
satellites are picking up all that damn
gas coming off the city I talked about
that one of the earlier
and man there were rumors that they were
they were taking people old people and
zipping them up in those body bags and
cremate them why they were still
technically alive that's some [ __ ] there
huh yeah they were dying but you know I
mean they're like in comas and stuff
they burn most enough I wonder if that's
true I bet you that might be true for
China I don't know I don't want to cast
this person I don't know you know how
you know how it is when societies start
[ __ ] panicking and there's a bunch of
dead bodies I mean it's like zombie
apocalypse yeah there's like I'm walking
dead as soon as you get bit they just
like search and then yeah well there was
a lot of stuff going on into plague you
know then black and the Black Death you
know throwing people on cart well and it
was it probably sucked a lot more back
then because they couldn't really
determine right like when someone was
dead or I didn't really have evidently
they were throwing people alive on those
carts though I don't doubt that word
they were not conscious but they were
alive yeah cuz they knew the pattern
they were like well you're that bad
you're gonna die yeah just like yeah
probably only hours away anyway so let's
go ahead and just get him on this trip
yes sir your last hours on earth right
like underneath like a bunch of what the
[ __ ] bodies
thanks man yeah you know imagine some
imagine practicality kind of takes takes
over well yeah and maybe I mean
hopefully most of them were so far gone
that they didn't realize what was going
on because they really blow like like
your last few minutes on earth this is
such a cheerful show well they were
probably your family yeah that's - yeah
because they were dying into old family
groups
yeah I mean and oh speaking of cheerful
um so it's official I started writing
faceless villain for today oh you did so
yeah so I've been working on some
various cases I did one case and I'm
working on another one the second one
that I'm working on I had totally
forgotten about this [ __ ] case you
remember um it happened like 10 months
after Columbine the Columbine shooting
you remember that oh yeah and it was the
same community was like two other
students and they were like in a subway
and somebody just came in and shot him
mmm right behind this is not a robbery
nothing and they still haven't solved it
it was like
twenty years ago they were kids that
were involved in the shooting no that
will they were students at that school
okay at Columbine High School no no they
were they just went to that school so it
wasn't retaliation for anything okay no
it's a no no no they came to my mind
they were just sophomores they it's
really weird because I mean the only
lead that they've had and I'm really not
sure if this even went anywhere but
there were rumors that maybe that Subway
restaurant was being used as like you
know to sell drugs out of and I think
even the mom of one of the victims
Stephanie Hart Brazell she like sued the
franchisee sit like you know contending
that they knew that there was a drug
ring going out of there and like they
didn't do anything about it but that
lawsuit didn't that they found in favor
of the franchisee like they couldn't
find any evidence of it but that's kind
of like the rumors have been swirling
around but I was just I had totally
forgotten until I was like looking at
all the articles and I saw their picture
and I was like oh [ __ ] I remember that
case and it was weird that it was like
it happened less than a year after the
Columbine shooting and it was students
that went to that school and you know
they didn't know like the shooters but
they you know knew some of the people
that have been killed and that was kind
of like messed up and it's [ __ ] up
that they never caught the guy that did
it they have a description and like um
you know like a sketch and stuff but
they still haven't [ __ ] caught him
and like creeps me out but yeah so I was
writing about that and then I was
writing about another one in Anchorage
Alaska where apparently like a lot of
Native women get murdered up there the
same kind of thing is like the highway
of tears like in British Columbia or
whatever and um most of them are like
not solved but something that I didn't
know about I don't know if it's Alaska
is or hold or just Anchorage but even
though Native women are only 4% of the
population they account for 50% of the
victims of sexual assault and their
rapists are almost always of a different
race are you white right truckers yeah
white truckers so um what are they doing
are they they're working there's a lot
lizards no they're not nope okay
and it's like that's what I mean it's
like the these aren't like prostitutes
in survey it's like I said so it's not
exactly like highway of tears because a
lot of those women were because I don't
know if they were all prostitutes but
some of them are like hitchhiking and
stuff you better just hang around by
those roads and there's nothing but
truckers going down there and that's the
that's probably you know they said that
that's a very common job for a killer is
to be a trucker yeah it is it's one in
one of the top five or maybe even top
three occupations because remember I
think we talked about this like a long
time ago but I came across this thing
that said like the top five you know the
top five occupations of serial killers
and yet trucker was up there and there
was also some [ __ ] about they I mean
they usually work like I think that one
was like forestry ranger or people that
like work out in the yeah so you know
[ __ ] like that that that kind of crap um
but yeah you really you're in the saying
that the guy that's in that it's gonna
want to have a job or he's constantly
moving and he doesn't have any
supervision there's no yeah that's what
I'm saying so so I don't think that it's
like truckers you know
disproportionately become serial killers
I think people that are inclined towards
serially come those draw are drawn to
that because they feel like oh I can
just go all over the country and just
dump women everybody's watch like no
one's watching me and like you know so
yeah it's like it's a job that really
appeals to somebody with those
proclivities I guess but yeah so those
are the first couple cases that I was
working on today this is gonna be like I
said I was like trying to I was really
trying to I had to establish some
parameters right because there's so many
unsolved murders and I was like I can't
put all the [ __ ] things in the book
or I'll be working on this book for ten
[ __ ] years so I made like the
parameters I said okay well there has to
be at least three articles that's about
this particular case not one of those
ones it's like oh here's the 10 like
unsolved murders in this town or
whatever because some of them and then
it just has like a couple sentences
about each one so I said it has to have
at least three articles about this
particular case or it has to be part of
like a purported series because one of
the women that I was writing about an
anchorage there wasn't a lot of
information about her case in particular
but there had been a bunch of other
murders in anchorage of native women
that happened around the same time or
just like in a couple of year
period I don't know if it was all the
same person doing it or if it was just
kind of like a thing but it seemed like
a series so I was like okay well I put
that in there but even with that I'm
still working on the first chapter which
is mm I still think there's like at
least 20 cases in this one chapter so
it's like this book is gonna take
forever I'm sorry I really really wanted
to have it done by the end of the year
we'll see I'm really gonna work hard but
what if every single chapter has that
many [ __ ] cases in it I'm just like
oh god this is gonna take so long but
you know I'll work on it I'll work on it
yeah so uh this is probably kind of
short but you have anything else she
wanted to go into today researching more
on our boy see this ago I was doing a
bit of that this morning - I ran
simulations I found some really funny
like some other people have done videos
like how much they hit him and how much
of a douchebag yes f it's very very and
then also more stuff about Aikido and
[ __ ] oh yeah yeah [ __ ] oh so
these people don't know probably now I
don't know if you're new to the show or
not even that [ __ ] oh is [ __ ]
based upon Bushido Bushido and [ __ ]
oh yeah it's long story
martial arts martial arts bulls we did a
show about it a while back which which
was very entertaining if my they said
myself I mean it was we had a good time
with that [ __ ] [ __ ] right and I'm and
I'm looking forward to doing this even
Seagal alone because you you guys like
we saw and we'll probably get into this
a little bit more of the show but I
think Netflix that was the only Steven
Seagal movie they had was the 1069 road
or something or other sniper special ops
made like six movies that year man it
was movies he's not really in them he
was in this we make severances for maybe
five minutes or maybe 10 minutes he
walked a couple of times one time when
he walked down stairs he had a stunt
double well here's the thing walk down
stairs there sure it's a big walkie tip
like he's supposed to be walking down
the stairs yeah like from and I made a
joke it's like I would probably had to
get a stunt double from for doing that
but then I look I'm like oh look too
fast so he got a guy who was a little
bit skinnier than him go down a stairs
pour anything all they didn't show his
face I mean the reason everybody makes
fun of him is just because he's such a
self-important I wanted to see I just
want
see the movie to see what race he was in
this movie yeah it's like whatever
decide what la si was supposed to be
he's black or what accident now he's to
have he's southern he's he's Cajun he's
New York he's I don't know if he's Irish
he's Chinese been that he's been all
races he's all he was and he was doing
this [ __ ] before
race race racial swapping of characters
like in like in like in comic books he
was the first guy to come up with it he
was a different race in every [ __ ]
movie and like I said his accent was
different and every like and even like
even when he's not in a movie like you
wouldn't because he did like a [ __ ]
reality show or some [ __ ] like that yeah
he does it just walking around yeah and
he's like talking I'm like why are you
talking like a hip-hop artist all of a
sudden yeah and they're like or
sometimes he talks like and whenever in
like rednecky and I'm just like what how
what is his real voice and when he's
ever went way when he's a cop arrests in
black people he's black yeah yeah I got
that [ __ ] on video I know yeah trying to
think of what else said he'd that [ __ ]
does is funny we had nobody's here on
the waitrons um just I was just looking
at it I was also looking at him in his
prime you know I mean when he was really
doing Aikido when he was young and I
noticed something maybe I'll save that
for the show yeah but I just wanted to
mention we did notice like we didn't sit
through the whole movie on Netflix we
just like out of curiosity because we
were like you know you know kind of
drinkin and we were just kind of like to
wait as the Netflix have any [ __ ]
Steven Seagal movies let's see and they
and I think they only had that one and
it was um we didn't sit there and watch
the whole thing cuz I couldn't stand it
was so boring it was yeah yeah we're
just like they're very kind of like
mass-produced
cheap quick to make everybody else is
doing all the acting he's not acting in
it it's what was the company that did
not cease at the center of the earth
what's named that [ __ ] up crazy ass
it's not Asylum is it now I think of my
abuse asylum is the one that does all
those like really blatant ripoff
yeah it's like every single me you know
like Jurassic Park comes out and they do
like Jurassic mark or something yes or
something like those were Dinosaur Park
I think was the one yeah those movies
are actually better than his movies they
are yes sir entertaining they're
entertaining their ferrets never know
what they are but yeah yeah and this
always just dull they're just dull
they're dull and he's a bunch of people
sit around mumbling at each other I
think I think what it is is that we see
I'm not gonna who did the show that
we're make it's not it's not gonna be a
[ __ ] Steven Seagal hate fest I mean
we're gonna give a guy you made me laugh
I'm trying to lie it's not gonna be a
Steven Seagal hate fest I like Steven
Seagal but I liked his early movies well
most people like I like to say movies
but you watch those movies for a certain
thing and he did give it to you you know
I mean it was a certain time and a place
for that kind of movie there was an era
of that kind of movie he was kind of the
bottom wrong of that kind of action yes
in a way but he was still pretty good I
really understand 1 & 2 I liked it hard
to kill I liked it
summers [ __ ] but there were certain
things about him you know I mean you can
only suspend your disbelief for so long
you know I mean and that's what happened
with him and II he was he's acting bad
around people he he's a crazy person
he's definitely crazy yeah yeah yeah
that's part of his crazy I think he just
doesn't realize he just I think he kind
of bought into the I'm a genius and I'm
a superhero and I know it's best for
everybody and I'd say that's what I
think happened he bought into that he
became that yeah he vanished up his own
ass yeah he vanished up his own ass you
know and he's gonna [ __ ] be a shitty
Otsu master if I couldn't walk around
looking for breast cancer yeah that's it
might be a lump you know turn this way
to the classy stairs you
that I don't think I don't really think
he came from much and I think he just
talked his way into this [ __ ] out of it
and we got a lot of evidence too
everybody knows that I think now but I
also want to kind of revelant
it almost we're gonna celebrate we're
gonna celebrate we're gonna the wonder
that is stevis ago
well I'm calling the show he is
interesting it's a fascinating man I
find I find very interesting
he's very interesting just because he's
so like not self-aware it's a phenomenon
that I find that very interesting Steven
Seagal was a [ __ ] phenomenon yeah all
right
I'm gonna call the show the enduring and
nygma yes exactly was like and I think
got a guy from that other channel he had
the wall of Segal whole he did and he
had stevia Steven Seagal action figures
he didn't which some people might you
know [ __ ] good why the [ __ ] I totally
understand it I told he's like a living
myth yeah ya know what is there a final
pop figure of him I'm sure there's one
of everything it's like something that's
not true because I don't think it is
true but it's part there it is rooted in
something that's true yeah I watched him
douche do Aikido he was good for Aikido
just yeah it wasn't real isn't really
really I'll get into it more on the show
yeah
Aikido the thinking behind Aikido is
very Japanese it would have only worked
in Japan with a bunch of milquetoast
[ __ ] you know the man that
don't really fight you know and don't
really want to fight that I well it's a
lot of my fighting it's not really far
it's mostly kind of like moving a
[ __ ] and putting them other
[ __ ] in check and but it never would
only work on somebody who doesn't really
resist it you're good Aikido all you
want I don't want to be impolite and
fight back and that's that was something
I think back in those days yeah yeah
that thing I think that was in the time
in which the guy who invented
Aikido that's kind of the way Japanese
Upen kind of was ya know
I mean very polite very polite and they
were you know kind of shy people and
they're not not big not not much
physical prowess they were all they're
all the same race so they're all kind of
similar size and weight you know they're
eating the same diet in that era people
didn't really work out
in Japan they didn't work out maybe they
were gonna we're gonna rice paddy work
in a factory something you know any but
it's this everyone is kind of the same
you know I'm talking about physically
they're kind of of the same abilities
so maybe Aikido you could push somebody
aside or put somebody in check or like I
mean do some kind of weird hold and get
him to submit but only if they didn't
really fight back it's really all you're
so sorry you know like that yeah
yeah I'll get more into it in the show
that yeah cuz we got a we gonna do a
whole show on Aikido not a whole show
but I can talk more about Aikido on the
show and there's like so many funny
story toes not in Aikido is a martial
art it's a real martial art but yeah it
is it's not an effective martial art
that's almost well not like not for you
know in the sense that like you know it
was about a knives martial arts fighters
it was about non-aggression they didn't
even punch pin yeah Dan you know I mean
it was it was mostly like moving
somebody and like hey [ __ ] work
you're gonna fight you're gonna fight an
MMA fighter with that you're gonna get
going to a bar and defend yourself
against some [ __ ] bruiser that's
[ __ ] beating the [ __ ] out of you with
the kid no you get your ass handed to
you yeah yeah it's true yeah all right
so before we wrap up a Thursday's show
I'm gonna do another book recommendation
and this one is a little bit
self-serving he's good
however check this is good this is a
good book though this is a zombie
anthology called history is dead oh
there was a look from what somebody
recommended a friend of mine recommended
we need to go on Netflix and watch a
zombie movie called Kingdom oh yeah yeah
that's a series they wouldn't also the
series are in series but I've heard
taking place like in feudal China yeah
ancient China's an ancient Chinese
zombies I gotta see that yeah I heard
someone like some people talking about
this is good but yeah this is um it's
from permeated press edited by Kim
Pathan Roth and this not only does have
like the best cover ever I don't know
who designed it I couldn't find their
name on here but um I have a story in
here called the anatomy lesson and all
the other stories are rad as well so you
should definitely check that out if you
like zombie stuff there they're all like
a historical zombie movies my story is
set in 17th century Holland and
Rembrandt is in it oh [ __ ] as well as a
zombie okay so you know check that out
so you're ready to wrap up the Thursday
show all right so we're wrapping up the
Thursday show take care out there and we
will talk to you again tomorrow